a couple things I wanted to add
listening to what Mark said one is I was
talking about characters what does the
character want that's if there was only
one character in the scene I think what
you always want to look for as a writer
is if you've got two or more characters
in the scene you want to create a
situation where they want opposing
things or or because otherwise there's
no conflict or one way to look at it is
every scene is a power grab everybody
wants to take control of the situation
in whatever way that means to them and
so how are they sort of secretly
jockeying for position you know like he
and I do like which of us we're all just
worried we're worried about which of us
looks smarter see that's what this whole
interview has been the other thing that
you said about the quite the the desires
on the part of the character I was
thinking I know you said there's a lot
more than two but two more I would think
about as the writer besides what were
the two you said what does the character
well know that the two different
objectives yeah Missy when I broke it
down to Michael is what I call the
public objective right in other words if
I asked fact anybody in this room now
what what are you doing here what do you
want what's your objective right now we
could talk about we're doing this
interview that's a public objective then
there's underneath that deep under there
is a private objective which may not
even be recognized well yeah that's what
I was it may be in the unconscious
what's driving that character to try to
do that right and one way I would look
at it it's not quite the same as a
desire is to ask what is the character
hiding from the other person consciously
what is she hiding from him and what is
she hiding from herself what's the thing
that she's not yet aware of that is
really driving her and you know
underneath especially in the first half
or 3/4 of the movie towards the end
you'd hope that all that would come to
the surface but deception and secrecy
are very very powerful in telling a
story because they add a whole new layer
of conflict they get into this
inner journey stuff and they'll and the
more conflict on the more layers the
more you're gonna pull in your audience
that's good I like the hiding thing I
didn't see because I was into that yeah
there's subconscious or the unconscious
or the you know unaware of but the
hiding and deception is secrecy that's
good
I'm gonna steal that can I steal that oh
sure I'll get yours thank you
well you could still use it I mean I've
got taking it forever okay you want to
share it you don't want to steal no I'm
not gonna stay yeah I'm not gonna lie
we're clear that my agenda is to look
better
I'll give you credit for it okay good
okay because we know my stated objective
is to look smarter I think we yes I'm
trying and I'm trying to help you with
them appreciate that I'll help you think
you're winning thank you let's move on
that was great let's move on
you